So now that we know what simulates the will of the AI agent, it's time to look at what drives the logic and the memory behind the AI agent.
The Behaviour Tree can be best described as the brain of the AI.
In fact, the Behaviour Tree component inherits directly from the brain component.
The Behaviour Tree component is held by the AI controller and indeed makes a clear assumption that it's owned by an AI controller,
with functions such as GetAIOwner being made available to programmers.
It's also strongly paired with a Blackboard component, exposing functions to developers that allow us to retrieve the Blackboard component from the Behaviour Tree directly.
It's important to note that although the ownership pairing has been established in the code architecture,
the AI controller does not come with a brain component already attached.
This can be done by a developer through Blueprint or C++, however.
Lastly, if you choose to add the Behaviour Tree component through Blueprint,
the native C++ code of the AI controller will automatically search for a brain component on itself and set its own member variables accordingly.
The Behaviour Tree component allows developers to plug in their desired Behaviour Tree in the editor and have it be run immediately upon possession.
Alternatively, we can explicitly call RunBehaviourTree ourselves and pass through a specific tree as and when we find it suitable.
If a Behaviour Tree component is not present when calling RunBehaviourTree, then one will be created for you.
The Behaviour Tree component is in charge of running our AI logic, that being the Behaviour Tree asset.
As already mentioned, it will start the AI logic on possession and stop AI logic on unpossess.
It will also tick the Behaviour Tree directly for us.
We can also use it to pause the Behaviour Tree's logic.
The brain component on the AI also features a special messaging system that the AI logic can utilise.
You'll find examples of these already in the engine.
These messages allow us to know what may have gone on during the processing of a piece of AI logic.
For example, in our MoveTo task, we can determine whether or not we succeeded or failed in our move.
This will determine whether or not we proceed onto the next node in the tree or fail the whole node in its entirety.
A Behaviour Tree allows an AI agent to do their thinking and make decisions that drive their functionality.
A Behaviour Tree can be paired with a Blackboard to efficiently make decisions, although it isn't strictly necessary to use one.
However, it is still highly recommended that you do use a Blackboard.
As we mentioned previously, the Blackboard component and the Behaviour Tree component have been strongly paired in the code architecture.
Behaviour Trees are created within the editor, as can be seen in the image here.
And we simply right-click in the Content Browser, go to the Artificial Intelligence category, and select the Behaviour Tree option.
Behaviour Trees are built in a hierarchical set of nodes that control the flow of decision making, which we're going to cover shortly.
In Unreal, Behaviour Trees are event-driven, which avoids doing unnecessary polling every frame.
The Behaviour Tree passively listens for events that can then be used to trigger changes in the tree.
This type of code architecture means that we do not need to iterate over the entire tree every tick,
so instead we rely on the messages to inform us of these changes.
They also help with debugging Behaviour Trees, as we can simply only show the relevant information at the time that it was being executed.
Here we've got an example of a simple Behaviour Tree, in which the AI agent can either move towards the player and attack them,
or if they've not yet perceived a player, they will patrol randomly until they do perceive one.
Behaviour Tree branches are executed in order.
When authoring your own Behaviour Trees, you'll notice that all of the nodes have been assigned a number when they're placed in the graph.
This numerical value tells us the order in which these nodes will be executed.
So at the higher level, the Behaviour Tree executes top to bottom, whilst on a branch level we execute left to right.
This is critical to understand when authoring your own Behaviour Trees.
You wouldn't want an AI agent to prefer patrolling to chasing and engaging with the player.
It's also important to understand that nodes in the Behaviour Tree can be moved around and will update their execution order
based on their position at runtime, so clean and well spaced out Behaviour Trees are a must.
So on the previous slide, Behaviour Trees come with their own editor graph, and as such have their own graph nodes.
Behaviour Trees are made up of five types of nodes, that being the root node, composite nodes, task nodes, decorator nodes and service nodes.
So let's take a look at what each one of these do.
The root node is the default node found in all Behaviour Trees,
and it serves as the starting point for a Behaviour Tree, and thus cannot be deleted.
This unique node within the tree has got a few special rules.
Firstly, the root node can only have one connection,
and if that connection to the root node is removed, then the entire tree is disabled.
Next, it does not support attaching of decorators or service nodes.
And lastly, the root node does not have any inherent properties.
However, when you select it, you'll be shown the properties of the Behaviour Tree on the whole.
As we can see with this example, selecting the root node allows us to set the Behaviour Tree's blackboard.
So now we've got our root node, but in its own right it doesn't really do a lot.
This is where the composite nodes come in.
Composite nodes define the root of a branch.
As well as this, they also determine the rules for how a branch is executed,
and we'll see how each one of the composite nodes goes on to define these in the following slides.
Another important thing to note about composite nodes
is that they are the only type of node that can be attached to that root node.
Composite nodes support both decorator and service nodes,
and decorators allow us to control how we either enter the branch,
or even cancel out mid execution.
Services will only ever be active if the children of the composite node are being executed.
This is important to understand when we come to actually placing our service nodes.
There are three types of composite nodes that we can use,
that being the selector, the sequence, and the simple parallel.
Let's find out how each of these differ,
and what they offer to the engineer when developing our AI.
Let's start with the selector node.
The selector node will execute its children from left to right,
and it will stop executing when one of its children succeeds in its task.
If a child succeeds, then the selector node itself succeeds.
If all of its children fail, then the selector node itself will fail.
We can see as an example on the right
that the selector composite node will attempt to execute the first wait task,
however its decorator will cause it to fail after one second, thus failing the task.
Instead of failing straight away,
the selector node will execute the secondary wait task and thus succeed.
If we were to place a secondary task ahead of the first,
we would see that the task would succeed and the second would not run.
On the left, we can see that this composite node
also exposes two variables to developers,
the first being applied decorator scope.
If set, all decorators in the branch below
will be removed when execution flow leaves this branch,
but decorators on this node in particular will not be affected.
Lastly, we have the node name,
and this is just the readable name that this node should be assigned
when being displayed in the behavior graph editor.
It's usually a good idea to name your composite nodes
as it acts as a way to identify what this branch of your behavior tree is trying to do,
especially useful when your behavior trees start to grow in size.
Selectors are ideal for branches in which any sub-branch may perform a task,
but it does not matter which one of them is actually executed.
Next, we have sequence nodes.
Sequences also execute their children from left to right, much like the selector,
but a sequence node will stop executing once one of its children fails.
If a child fails, the whole sequence node will fail.
Conversely, if all the sequences' children succeed,
then the sequence will succeed.
In the example on the right, we can see there are three wait tasks,
with each executing one after the other.
If we were to place a similar condition to any of the other task nodes
like we did in the selector example,
we would see that the sequence would fail immediately
and not execute any of the children following the task that failed.
Sequences are ideal for things such as moving towards a target,
as we would likely run an environment query to find out a location to move to,
then proceed to that location.
On the left, we can see a similar set of properties
that we would see in the selector node,
and they do exactly the same thing.
Lastly, we have the simple parallel node.
The simple parallel node allows a single main task node
to be executed alongside a full tree.
When the main task finishes,
depending on what finish mode that we've got selected,
the other tree will either be aborted immediately,
or will simply wait until it finishes.
Simple parallel nodes are great for things such as
moving continuously whilst also shooting.
Decorator nodes are the next type of node that we need to look at.
They can be attached to either composite or task nodes,
but they cannot be placed on their own.
They define whether a node or branch can be executed at all,
and they're also known as conditionals in other behavior tree systems.
Lastly, decorator nodes can also be used to abort parts of a behavior tree,
allowing us to bail out of the execution of a branch
midway through that execution.
So, on to task nodes.
The task nodes are nodes that do things,
so for example, move on an AI or editing a blackboard key.
Tasks support both decorator and service nodes,
and other than composite nodes,
task nodes are the only other node type
that can be placed down onto the behavior graph itself.
There's a wide choice of tasks already implemented in Unreal,
one of which we can already see in the example below,
that being the move to task.
Much like decorator nodes,
we can create our own task nodes in both Blueprint and in C++.
And lastly, we're going to come to services.
Services are nodes that will execute at a defined frequency
when their branch is being executed.
Services can be used to perform checks
or update data about the world
that can then be used in place of parallel nodes
that you might have otherwise used in other behavior tree systems.
Unreal comes with two services supported out of the box,
the first being Default Focus.
This service will set the focus actor directly on the AI controller.
This can be especially useful
for getting hold of a set actor in Blueprint or C++,
instead of having to access the data directly on the blackboard.
The second is RunEQS.
This service can be used to regularly run
an environment query system template as an assigned interval
and will update the given blackboard value with the result.
Lastly, it's important to note that although services do tick,
you don't have to use them in that way.
Services come with functions that allow developers
to know when a service has come into relevancy of the tree
and when it has ceased to be relevant,
so they don't have to be ticking all of the time.
So now that we know all the different types of nodes that we have access to,
we should discuss how you utilize memory in the behavior tree.
Behavior tree nodes exist as shared objects,
meaning that all AI agents using the same behavior tree
will share the same single set of node instances.
This approach has a two-fold effect.
The first is that it improves CPU performance,
and secondly, it reduces memory usage.
It does, however, come with a caveat,
that being that the shared nodes cannot store agent-specific data in their headers.
However, if we do find ourselves needing to store agent-specific data,
Unreal offers support to do so in three different ways.
So let's cover the first way in which you can do so.
That would be instancing your nodes.
Behavior tree nodes expose out a bool
that allows us as developers to instance the node,
and this is the bCreateNodeInstance parameter.
If this is set to true, then this will grant each AI agent
using this behavior tree a unique instance of that node.
This will, of course, allow us to store some agent-specific data
with the downside of actually having a higher memory and CPU cost
to a non-instance version of the node.
There are examples of usage of these node types
within Unreal's own implementation,
such as the play animation task and the run behavior dynamic task.
The second way in which we can get around this
is by using the Blackboard storage.
The Blackboard storage can be accessed within nodes
to get agent-specific data,
and key functions in our nodes send through
the AI agent's behavior tree component as one of its parameters.
As developers, we can simply expose an fName property
to make use of a Blackboard key selector
to allow us to get and set data from and to the Blackboard.
It's important to note that this approach
can only support Blackboard data types,
which we're going to discuss in just a second.
And lastly, we've got the node memory.
Unreal allows developers to create a custom struct or class
to store variables inside the node's memory.
Many of the functions in behavior tree nodes
pass through a Uint8 pointer parameter,
and this parameter indicates the block of memory
that has been allocated to our AI agent.
The get instance memory size function,
which must be implemented if we're going to use the memory approach,
will dictate the size of this block of memory.
Nodes will allocate this amount of memory for each AI agent,
and the node memory is stored in a single continuous block
to optimize performance.
However, it's very important to keep in mind
that node memory is not part of the U object ecosystem,
so our memory is not visible to the garbage collector.
It's highly recommended that when dealing with reflection types
that we make use of the Tweek object pointer
to hold your variable.
We can see an example of how this is done
in the next slide,
and this example is lifted from the move to task
already implemented in Unreal.
So now we've covered the simulated will of the AI
and the brains of the AI.
Now we need to discuss the memory of the AI.
The blackboard is a special asset type
that is created specifically to work in conjunction
within the behavior tree.
It's used to store information in the shape of a blackboard key.
This information can then be queried by the behavior tree
at runtime to make informed decisions.
A blackboard can store up to 255 entries
and they can also support parent blackboards.
This means we can inherit keys from other blackboards.
The blackboard component offers programmers the entry way
for querying and saving data to and from the blackboard respectively.
The blackboard component is strongly paired
to the behavior tree component.
It will cache the component and programmers can retrieve
the brain component of the AI directly from the blackboard component.
The blackboard component also follows a similar pattern
to the behavior tree component in terms of creation.
It's not present by default on the AI controller
and much like the behavior tree component,
it can either be added via blueprints or C++.
However, this isn't necessary as one will be created
when the AI logic is triggered to start.
But it's also important to note that the blackboard
is not essential to running the AI logic
as we mentioned earlier.
Again, much like the behavior tree component,
the blackboard component does expose a blackboard asset
to the editor which can be plugged in directly.
The blackboard component also offers a unique callback functionality
that allows objects to register as observers
of a particular blackboard key
so that they can be notified when that blackboard value has changed.
A blackboard can store the following data types.
We can store a lot of our expected basic types
such as vector, rotator, bool, int32, float, and string
as well as enum.
But we can also store some much more unreal specific types
such as the fname, uobject, and uclass.
If you wish to look at how data for each of these keys
is actually manipulated, then we'd highly recommend you
take a look at the BlackboardKeyAllTypes header
which will give us a handy include
for all of the types that we listed above.
Lastly, it's important to note that a blackboard
cannot store arrays of data.
The blackboard works off of a single block of memory
and data types are stored with offsets
based off of their data size.